this fight's back wow look at that
reaction from Magnus Carlson he's on the
clock and again totally agree with David
black is just dominating the position
and it's all to do with that pawn
um when you said that's not just any
phone it felt like a marks and Spencer
Advent yeah and okay Black's Rook now
trying to undermine the white Rook
trying to eliminate the blockade of
black spawn White's Bishop trying to
cause some chaos directly to take a bomb
with check but Magnus blocking the white
Bishop it's not just game over here
there's nothing to be done one second in
the piece
Magnus fights back wow look at that
reaction from Magnus Carlson
Wesley's not gonna make it yeah I think
he's going to lose on the clock Wesley
if he doesn't lose on the board he still
needs to save it on the board especially
after that last move white Spirit
getting active Wesley smiling
he knows it's going to be all over soon
20 seconds and Magnus wins wow look at
that Magnus Carlsen in Armageddon
finally beats Wesley so